chính phủ Australia dự kiến từ tảng 12 tởi sẽ ám dụng lình cấm các nền tảng mạng xa hộ như Facebook, Instagram,
Tích chóc và Snapchat cho chè em dưới Mỹ sấu tối.
Bắt đầu, YouTube được nghiệm chứ về lý sợ giáo dục và sức khỏe.
Tuy nhiên, sau đây sốt mới từ 8 an tàn diện từ, chính phủ đang cân nhắc sức chặt quản lý với cả YouTube.
Đúng thế này, hiện Google, chụi sử dụi YouTube, gửi tức thành báo sẽ hợi kiện,
đưa chính phủ đứa nền tảng này vào xem xe cấm.
Google lập lận rằng YouTube là dịch vụ phát triệt đuyến không phải mạng xa hội,
ra đó không thực phản vì lệnh cấm.
Chỉ phủ Australia khẳng định ước tinh hàng đầu là bỏng về chè em trước tăng động tiêu cực từ lộ dụng trực đuyến.
Với định khuỡ công sẽ anh hưởng lớn đến mối trường pháp đi, cho các nền tảng xấu,
đông thời tạo tin lệ cho nhiều cuối ra khác trong khoản lý mạng xa hội và quyền tiếp cận thùng tin của chè em.